when you came to Saturday Night Live
think about it Lorne Michaels had left
and now he was coming back yes and you
were part of that cast that was hired to
revive Saturday Night Live right
85 the cast was put in a fake fire yeah
and they they they they kept Dennis
Miller Nora Dunn and Jon Lovitz
yeah and that was it and then Phil
Hartman and Jan hooks and I came in with
Kevin Nealon and we were told I don't
even know I've never asked Lauren this
but we were told if we didn't we had to
hit the ground running we we had an 8:00
show pick up right the show was gonna
get canceled at Christmas oh if we
didn't do something isn't that amazing
because yeah you know certain I'd like
to only have an H Oh pick up it shows
you how bad a shape it was in I heard it
was cancelled right
and then someone Bernie Brillstein went
to Brandon and said you've got to give
Lauren one more chance he was Lauren's
manager and so Lauren was banking on you
so much that I don't think he's ever
done this with anyone before you even
you know he hires you for Senate life
yeah and he puts you up in his house and
he lets you live there until the show
starts
yes what was the reason behind that that
you had no money or that he wanted to
somehow indoctrinate you into the
Saturday Night Live family put it in
context is not a joke so I'm doing clubs
I'm playing a pizza parlor in Martinez
California all right they're like four
people this is in July
wasn't it surreal when you're staying at
Lorne Michaels in Warren is a group you
know here you're about to go start I was
playing the pizza parlor now I'm hanging
at Lauren Michaels yeah you go from zero
to six yeah you know or 160 crazy
you're hanging out at Lauren Michaels
house and and Paul McCartney was there
that summer he's hanging out with you in
that house you're staying in Jack
Nicholson's room yeah I mean was
everybody yes and and when Paul
McCartney walks in do you start doing
the paul mccartney more no Paul's coming
over tonight you know and I'll never
forget that poem that would be Paul
McCartney so I'm already Cantrell even
look at Lauren Michaels I'm so terrified
and I did answer the door and it was
Paul McCartney and Lynda and the house
was empty just me Lauren a Whitney Brown
Chevy was next door he came over later
Wow and
all did say to me your face is gone a
bit funny so I guess I just turned
bright red or something so this was a
presence of mind thing for anyone who
meets a celebrity I at the moment I
thought okay I'm not gonna mention the
Beatles this was like 86 which is such a
shame that you can't say to Paul
McCartney can I talk to you about the
Beatles but I know cool right you got to
be cool over you gotta be cool but I I
picked out an album called tug of war
he'd done in 1981 in the title song tug
of war and I said well in the course of
the that's song when you said one day we
will stand up on top of the mountain
with the flag unfurled but it won't be
soon enough for me what were you
thinking Paul loved me after that we
became so then after that he mean if you
if you would called in like Blackbird as
a reference if I'd said who played the
drums on dear Prudence you wouldn't like
that did we only have one song and there
was a list of stupid things I could say
so he's sitting right next to me and
he's playing a disc of the new song he'd
record had never been on an album and
this is what I'll never forget four
people haven't heard this story so
there's a Whitney brown Chevy Chase
Lauren Michaels Paul and Linda and
you're a kid who hasn't never been on TV
I mean nobody you feel like the help I
mean I totally yeah do people call who
is this guy what's he doing oh this is
my new prodigy yeah exactly but they
were so sweet because my wife wasn't
with me at the time she was staying in
California because I said everything I'd
ever done was canceled I'll be back in
six weeks she had a good job right but
they were very worried Paul and Linda
you know they said we're we don't like
that Paul was not here with you you know
not only know one in five minutes of it
charming but he leans into me right as
the song starts to me who he'd met 10
minutes before and said and this is
exactly how it sounded you know you know
Dane sometimes when you're writing you
try so hard to live up to whatever you
end up ruining the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know what a thing for him to them up
to you know and then the next night he'd
had a new album press to play and I said
yeah bring it tomorrow though I didn't
think they'd remember so they'd come
over at nine o'clock they I go oh you
brought the album
press to play Linda says DePaul see I
told you he'd want to hear it so they
were having conversations about so that
whole thing was surreal